[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
surprise à Vichy pour les 15000
spectateurs venus assister à
l'inauguration du nouveau et magnifique
plan d'eau de l'Allier le premier
championnat du monde de cerf-volant
humain un sport qui bien entendu nous
arrive tout droit des plages de Floride
et de Californie
[Musique]
rien de plus facile et d'abord le
décollage
tirer à 75 km/h par un canot automobile
les champions planent à 40 mètres
au-dessus de l'eau
une main
l'autre on descend
[Musique]
et le repas rien de plus facile du moins
pour ses champions
autour maintenant du Hollandais jurgence
avec Jürgens ce n'est plus tout à fait
du cerf-volant c'est aussi du trapèze
[Musique]
mais que dire alors de Thomas Jones ce
Venezuela lui même plus besoin de ski
d'ailleurs son cerf-volant qui a déjà du
parachute
[Musique]
mission terminée un sport qui devrait
faire fureur l'an prochain sur la Côte
d'Azur
[Musique]
à Vichy également 37e championnat de
France de boules tous les spécialistes
français du cochonnet étaient fidèles au
rendez-vous
ici la finale du championnat catégorie
honneur
a beaucoup au but du pointeur
[Musique]
Barbie acharnée également en coupe des
jeunes ces champions de demain ne s'en
laissent déjà pas compter on discute on
palabre on mesure comme des vétérans
[Musique]
finalement l'honneur de Lyon berceau de
la boule était sauf les Lyonnais à titre
sur 3
[Musique]
poussez protégé canaliser par les
autorités fédérales la grande marche des
noirs sur Washington a réuni quelques
200 000 manifestants cette marche
entreprise pour réclamer l'égalité des
droits entre blanc et noir aux
États-Unis fera-t-elle de cette journée
une date historique car on ignore pas
que le président Kennedy a mis au
premier plan de son programme
l'abolition de toutes ségrégation
[Musique]
station monstre ou l'ordre a toujours
été sauvegardé à démontré de la façon la
plus spectaculaire l'importance et
l'urgence d'une solution aux problèmes
noirs qui agite les États-Unis
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique à
Lisbonne une autre manifestation
réunissait sur la place du Commerce 250
000 personnes où se retrouver les
délégations des provinces d'outre-mer le
Portugal en effet considère non comme
colonie mais comme province et partie du
territoire national les territoires tels
que l'Angola et le Mozambique qu'il
occupent depuis le début du 16e siècle
cette foule était là pour donner son
adhésion à la détermination du président
Salazar de défendre à tout prix
l'intégrité nationale cette
détermination a-t-il dit doit être
interprétée partout comme l'affirmation
manifeste et courageuse de notre volonté
de vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en application du traité franco-allemand
on a vu à Sarrebourg une compagnie de
grenadiers allemands venir s'insérer à
la place d'une compagnie française dans
un régiment de chasseurs portés cantonné
à Sarrebourg près de près il ne semble
pas que cette intégration est posée de
véritables problèmes l'apprentissage
d'un matériel nouveau ne crée pas de
très grosses difficultés à des
techniciens et les 130 Allemands ont
très rapidement pris leur place sans à
coup dans leur nouvelle unité
ainsi les manoeuvres de char qui
utilisent le nouveau char français AMX
de 30 tonnes verront côte à côte dans
les mêmes groupes allemands et français
[Musique]
parallèlement une compagnie de chars
français a été intégrée pour trois
semaines à une Panzer Division à
Coblence
c'est sans la moindre gêne que les
Français ont pris possession de leur
cantonnement et dans la meilleure humeur
que ce sont déroulées de part et d'autre
les prises de contact ainsi peut-on dire
que ces opérations des changes
militaires sont réussies
[Musique]
que ces jeunes gens séparés hier par 150
ans d'histoire puisse retrouver à la
fois le sens de l'amitié et de la
Coopération c'est un fait plein de
promesses qui contient un germe la
meilleure part peut-être de l'avenir
européen
[Musique]
à Genève ou fut fondé la Croix-Rouge des
délégations internationales se sont
recueillies devant le monument élevé à
la mémoire d'Henri Dunant Henri Dunand
qui avec quatre autres genevois
lancèrent voici 100 ans son mémorandum
aux hommes de bonne volonté à travers la
ville un cortège qui groupait plus de
1500 participants représentant une
centaine de pays devait donner tous les
claques elle méritait à cette
commémoration du centenaire de la
Croix-Rouge internationale le 5 mai
généreuse qui a fait son chemin parmi
les hommes
[Musique]
c'est un jour de deuil pour l'art
universel comme pour la peinture
française Georges Braque est mort dans
sa petite maison parisienne où il vécut
ces derniers mois
vrac restera l'un des moments les plus
considérables de l'art moderne et il est
permis d'affirmer que sans lui et sans
Picasso le mouvement cubiste n'aurait
pas été ce qu'il fut une révolution
réussie l'expérience qu'il entreprite
aux environs de 1910 et qui devait
porter le nom de cubisme allait en effet
bouleversé les conceptions artistiques
dans le monde entier c'est de cette
expérience que devait sortir une
esthétique qui est aujourd'hui la base
même de l'art contemporain sous toutes
ses formes
tout un tiers livré à son art sans
compromission ni réserve la vie de
Georges Braque devait connaître avec
l'admiration universelle les
consécrations les plus officielles et ce
n'est certainement pas la moindre qui
lui ait été donné un jour comme support
à son talent l'un des plafonds du Louvre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une pensée que les chats américains
auraient un rôle à jouer dans la balance
économique française c'est pourtant ce
qui se passe depuis qu'une usine de la
région d'Angers fabrique à leur
intention des souris en tissu bourrés
d'herbe à chat sous l'oeil flegmatique
d'un matou angevin plus d'un million de
ses souris factices sont ici
confectionnés chaque année pour être
exportés aux USA
[Musique]
il est juste de préciser que les chiens
américains font aussi travailler cette
nouvelle industrie française de gadget
pour animaux pour eux on a mis au point
un guise d'os à moelle des bâtonnets à
base de chewing-gum dont il raffole
[Musique]
apparemment les chiens et les chats
d'Amérique s'ennuyaient ils peuvent
désormais meubler agréablement leur
loisirs pour la plus grande prospérité
d'une usine angevine ce qui tendrait à
prouver comme disait le panglos de
Voltaire que tout est pour le mieux dans
le meilleur des mondes possible
[Musique]
un souverain de 29 ans est arrivé en
visite à Paris une visite privée qui
doit cependant comporter des
conversations à l'Elysée pour usaint de
Jordanie que l'on a surnommé l'homme le
plus menacé du monde cette visite prend
un peu l'allure de vacances
rarement en effet la situation de son
royaume au coeur d'un Moyen-Orient en
effervescence lui laisse le loisir de
quitter Amman sa capitale
[Musique]
bâti sur l'ancienne Philadelphie romaine
dont il subsiste les restes d'un théâtre
antique Amman a pris son essor qu'avec
la création du royaume de Jordanie il
n'y a pas si longtemps de cela puisque
cette nation n'a quitte en 1946 alors la
ville ne comptait que 35 000 habitants
aujourd'hui Aman ne compte pas loin de
500 000 habitants le quart de la
population d'un pays de 80000 km² où le
désert domine
cette capitale qui a gardé malgré son
développement rapide l'aspect d'un gros
bourg traduit une volonté de
modernisation sans tapage dans son
palais d'Ammann le roi Hussein ne nous a
pas dit autre chose nous sommes
peut-être un petit pays mais notre seul
but est d'améliorer les conditions de
vie de notre peuple a-t-il expliqué
avant d'adresser un salut à la France je
voudrais bien envoyer à travers
actualités français mais amitié très
cordial à la grande nation française
il reste que la géographie dispose et
les soucis du roi Hussein suivent le
tracé des frontières jordaniennes la
frontière avait Israël fait de la
Jordanie la gardienne d'une partie des
lieux saints ce sans doute qui sont le
plus cher au monde chrétien le monde des
oliviers ou depuis deux millénaires vit
toujours le souvenir de la méditation du
Christ
[Applaudissements]
et puis la vieille Jérusalem celle où
chaque année des milliers de pèlerins
viennent refaire de ruelles en ruelle de
marche en marche le chemin que suivi
Jésus portant sa croix
[Musique]
c'est aussi dans la Jérusalem
jordanienne que s’élève la mosquée
d'Omar à la place même ou avait été bâti
le temple du roi Salomon
et aussi que s’élève le mur des
lamentations pèlerinage déserté par les
juifs depuis 1948 date de l'armistice
avec Israël car depuis cette époque un
mur a un franchissable coupe la ville
sainte mur un franchissable aux
israéliens dans lequel pourtant reste
ouvert le seul passage entre l'État
d'Israël et le monde arabe encore ne
franchitons cette porte que dans un sens
exception faite des voitures des Nations
Unies et le no man's land est là pour
rappeler que l'armistice n'est pas la
paix
[Musique]
depuis 1948 la célèbre légion arabe n'a
pas cessé de poursuivre un entraînement
intensif
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le professeur Calmette aurait 100 ans
aujourd'hui c'est lui qui avec Guerin
donna à l'humanité cette arme préventive
tant attendue contre la tuberculose le
BCG on devrait maintenant être à l'abri
du Fléau et pourtant prenez vous la
tuberculose
les faits sont éloquents faute de
vaccination des individus et des
individus jeunes sont atteints au point
qu'aux pays de Calmette la tuberculose
tue 6 fois plus qu'au Danemark ou le BCG
généralisé depuis longtemps
dans les villes surtout le refus de
certains malades adultes d'aller dans
sanatorium a même accru les risques de
contamination tuberculose auxquelles les
enfants sont particulièrement exposés il
importe d'assurer à ces derniers sans
exception la protection du BCG une
simple formalité en vérité mais cet acte
banal pratiqué dès le plus jeune âge
préservent les enfants d'affection
graves comme la méningite tuberculeuse
aucun incident sérieux ne risque de
résulter de cette méthode en effet les
millions de vaccinations réalisées dans
le monde à tous les âges se sont révélés
d'une extrême efficacité
99% de succès on a en contrôle du reste
aisément le résultat par la cutter
réaction qui renouvelait d'année en
année permet de s'assurer que le sujet
est toujours protégé
[Applaudissements]
en 1963 on ne devrait plus pouvoir se
priver de cette assurance sur l'avenir
le BCG
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ancien président du Conseil député de la
Moselle de 1919 à 1962 Robert Schuman
Emma la présence de cinq anciens chefs
de gouvernement dans le très long
cortège qui à Metz l'a accompagné à son
dernier voyage celle de Monsieur Louis
Jobs représentant le gouvernement celle
de nombreuses délégations françaises et
étrangères ont souligné la personnalité
de celui qui vient de disparaître et
dont la signature en 1951 fenêtre le
pool charbon acier première base de cet
édifice européen qu'il avait voulu de
toutes ses forces et auxquelles leur un
Néolux il n'avait jamais cessé de
travailler
le démembrement de l'Europe est une
cause permanente et croissante de
faiblesse dans tous les domaines
politiques économiques du 17
la mise en commun organique de nos
ressources seraient au contraire une
garantie de prospérité de puissance et
de paix
en 1953 commençait à couler le premier
acier qu'on pouvait bien nommer européen
puisqu'il n'existait plus pour lui de
frontières depuis l'unité de l'Europe a
fait son chemin la disparition des
barrières douanières est en route dans
le cadre du marché commun qui s'est
ajouté avec leur atome aux poules
charbon acier pour constituer un marché
de plus de 160 millions d'Européens
en 1958 Robert Schuman recevait à
Aix-la-Chapelle le prix Charlemagne qui
apportait une juste consécration à
l'oeuvre à laquelle il s'était voué avec
cet homme simple c'est un effet un grand
Européen qui s'en va l'un des pères
véritablement de l'Europe
[Musique]
son papa lui avait demandé de reprendre
les titres européens du sang et 200
mètres d'eau et Christine Caron est une
fille obéissante dans sa tentative
contre le record à la piscine Georges
Vallerey elle virait au 100m
dans la troisième longueur elle laissait
loin derrière elle les autres nageuses
et sans forcer se donnant même le luxe
de ralentir sa cadence elle touchait
enfin de course le mur en 2 minutes 32
secondes un dixième battant ainsi de
deux dixièmes le record d'Europe tant
au-dessous de ses possibilités aussi son
entraîneur lui a-t-il promis une
médaille aux Jeux Olympiques de Tokyo
[Musique]
finale des championnats du monde de ski
nautique à Vichy dans le slalom féminin
l'américaine Janet Brown remporte une
facilite victoire la française Dany
Duflot favorite mes blessés n'ayant pu
défendre ses champs
[Musique]
dans la France remportait une belle
victoire dans les figures cette jeune
fille de 15 ans pour son entrée dans
l'équipe nationale connaît du même coup
la consécration
[Musique]
ces championnats d'ailleurs se déroulent
sous le signe de la très nouvelle vague
l'Américain Spencer n'a pas plus de 14
ans l'année dernière champion des
juniors aujourd'hui champion du monde
des figures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il se donnait même le luxe le lendemain
de remporter le titre du slalom sourire
aux lèvres lancé à 60 km à l'heure il
passait siboué et ne rater la dernière
que de quelques centimètres du très
grand art
en saut le Suisse clair qui avait fait
42 mètres 70 à l'entraînement tombait et
l'Américaine Jackson remportait
l'épreuve avec un impeccable vol plané
de 40 mètres
[Musique]
et dans le défilé final Spencer
aiguillandal 29 ans à eux deux
symboliser la victoire des États-Unis et
de la France
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans la 15e fois en 5 ans le général de
Gaulle a rencontré le chancelier à de
Noël qu'il était venu accueillir à
l'aérodrome de Villacoublay les deux
hommes d'État ont passé le week-end au
Château de Rambouillet un week-end qui
devait être un week-end de Dieu puisque
le chancelier abandonne le gouvernement
de l'Allemagne fédérale mais les deux
artisans de la réconciliation
franco-allemande ont décidé de garder le
contact
[Musique]
des adieu beaucoup moins définitifs ont
été échangés entre parents et enfin à
l'école de Beneden près de Londres et on
pouvait voir notamment le roi Hussein de
Jordanie fait à ses derniers
recommandations à sa fille
[Musique]
mais la plus célèbre de ces jeunes
étudiantes était la princesse Anne que
sa mère était venue accompagnée la reine
Elizabeth avait tenu à conduire
elle-même sa fille au collège
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une première année de pensionnat pour
Anne dont l'éducation avait été faite
jusqu'à présent au palais de Buckingham
[Musique]
grand couturier ont prévu un hiver
rigoureux et les femmes seront en
étoufflées des pieds à la tête Lanvin
remplace les bas nylon par des bas de
laine d'un style très montagnard da et
culotte feront d'ailleurs bon ménage
Gardin de son côté préconise les bottes
cuissardes montent en haut sous la jupe
ou bottes de Draco secs qui rajeunissent
la silhouette un petit chapeau de curé
complétera de sa note irrespectueuse
cette tenue estudiante
m fait de la botte un accessoire luxueux
il traite la fourrure par-dessus la
jambe nouée négligemment sous le menton
ces pointes de fourrure protégeront les
élégantes contre la bise et la neige
cette mode si excentrique soit-elle ne
restera pas la panache de la haute
couture
chaussettes et bottes courront les rues
dès les premiers frimas en même temps
que les casques dignes de Valentina la
cosmonaute
[Musique]
et il ne faudra pas s'étonner si l'on
voit quelques jeunes personnes se
promenaient dans cette tenue originale
qui tient à la fois du motard du facteur
et de les gouttier
[Musique]
par un été qui fut un été pourri un
certain confort vestimentaire n'a pas
manqué d'être apprécié par les chanteurs
de l'équipe nerlandaise au moment
d'affronter les embruns de la mer du
Nord pour rallier la station belge de
Knokke-le-Zoute
venue de Hollande de France d'Italie
d’angleterre d'Allemagne et de Belgique
les chanteurs européens avaient
rendez-vous dans la station belge pour y
discuter la cinquième Coupe d'Europe du
tour de chant une coupe que devait
enlever la française Jacqueline Dano
surnommé la tragédienne de la chanson
je n'ai vraiment
plus rien à faire
plus rien
[Applaudissements]
la coquette Maurice Chevalier recevait
ses nombreux amis pour fêter à la fois
la Saint Maurice c'est 75 ans et sa
prochaine rentrée parisienne il est bien
vrai que celui qui créa voici quelques
lustres ménilmontins Valentine ou
prospère est apparu plus jeune que
jamais à tous ceux qui étaient venus le
féliciter d'Henri Varna Paul Derval
de Jean Rigaud à Henri Tiso
aussi n'est-ce pas seulement le passé
qu'on a évoqué à la look et tandis que
Maurice Chevalier soufflait les 75
bougies de son gâteau d'anniversaire on
ne songeait qu'à l'avenir
[Musique]
aux musical aussi les croulans se
portent bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un salon de Notre-Dame de Fourvière que
se dérouleront les Jeux Olympiques de
Lyon qui vient de célébrer son
millénaire et où l'on peut encore goûter
le charme de vieilles rues d'un autre
âge ambitionne d'être dans cinq ans
ville olympique le gouvernement a retenu
sa candidature pourquoi Lyon c'est que
cette ville en pleine expansion sur tous
les plans a des titres particuliers à
faire valoir tout d'abord son axe
routier nord-sud qui permet de traverser
la ville en un temps record et qui offre
une capacité de circulation qui à peu
près toutes les villes de France peuvent
lui envier
et puis surtout Lyon possède déjà des
installations sportives de classe
olympique
le long du Rhône on achève un ensemble
nautique qui contiendra 4 bassins
par ailleurs la cité de la soie dont le
nombre des piscines est passé depuis
1958 de 2 à 5 possède déjà une piscine
olympique
mais le plus beau fleuron à la couronne
sportive de Lyon c'est le Palais des
Sports qui a déjà cette année abrité
nombre de rencontres internationales
modernes vaste on serait tenté de dire
luxueux il peut contenir 15000
spectateurs
il n'est pas jusqu'au théâtre antique
qui ne puisse avoir sa place dans le
déroulement des jeux et qui est destiné
à servir de cadre discipline
gréco-romaine voilà pourquoi la
candidature de Lyon peut être retenue
pour le grand rassemblement olympique de
[Musique]
ah non des Jeux Olympiques de Tokyo
l'athlétisme français progresse à pas de
géant les athlètes russes en savent
quelque chose désormais le 100 mètres du
match France - Russie une merveilleuse
promenade du français pickman 10
secondes 3/10 une sérieuse science
olympique pour pig mal qui ne s'arrêtera
pas en si bon chemin
le 200 mètres c'est la répétition exacte
du 100 m
âle toujours lui s'envole vers une
nouvelle victoire mais cette fois
Jocelyn Delcourt devant ce soviétique
Haute-Saône pour la deuxième place
d'ailleurs presque toutes les courses
sans favorables aux Français
en revanche dans les concours les coloss
russes ne laisse aucune chance à leurs
adversaires kusenets of donne l'exemple
en remportant le javelot
le 1500 mètres on attendait avec
impatience à cause de Michel JAZY sa
cheville allait-elle tenir j'assis
rapidement rassure tout le monde mais le
soviétique caroloff tient absolument à
jouer les 3e larron et cela par tous les
moyens il joue des coups dans le virage
on prend un moment que Badoo et même
Jaji soit décroché et bien non les deux
Français se dégagent
et cela c'est l'illustration de la
volonté de vaincre de tous les athlètes
au cours de cette rencontre la plus
belle à laquelle est assistée les
Parisiens depuis de nombreuses années
ce match personne ne l'oubliera pas plus
que l'exhibition de Valérie Brunel le
Sputnik comme on l'appelle à Moscou il
franchit deux mètres 17 comme s'il était
à l'entrée
[Applaudissements]
ur Bernard et Turin ont pratiqué la
guerre d'usure à deux reprises
différentes sur le 5000 et sur le 10000
M Fiori n'était le plus fort il a gagné
les deux courses Bernard n'a pas à
rougir Turing sera peut-être champion
olympique à Tokyo sur l'une de ces deux
disques
enfin victoire française dans les relais
le 4 x 400 qui lui donne le match nul in
extremiste et le 4 x 100 que nous voyons
ici départ éclair de Lambron qui prend
l'avantage mais qui gâche tout en
passant le témoin à Genevet le rustère
vanescan lama tout faire de l'équipe qui
ajoute une belle pointe de vitesse à son
record du monde du saut en longueur
reprend le chemin perdu mais il y a
pYGMA
et avec lui la balance penche
définitivement du côté France
[Applaudissements]
avec vélocité une victoire dont personne
ne doutait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
finalement match nul 106 à 106 entre
deux grandes équipes d'athlétisme qui
fraternisent après une rencontre qui a
enthousiasmé tous les spectateurs de
colon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]